[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans dimanche
en politique votre émission de débat en
franche comté ce matin on va
s'intéresser ensemble au retour du loup
après plusieurs années discrète il
semble revenir pour de bon en franche
comté comme en atteste un récent
accident de voiture dans le haut doubs
alors comment préparer le retour du
prédateur dans notre massif du jura
faut-il se réjouir pour cette espèce
protégée ou bien s'inquiéter pour nos
éleveurs on va en débattre avec nos
trois invités
d'abord xavier broc et vous êtes
éleveurs de brebis aux rousses dans le
jura votre troupeau notamment a été
attaqué par un loup il ya quelques
années également sur ce plateau patrice
rey de l'est du pôle grands prédateurs
une association jurassienne qui veut
favoriser la cohabitation entre l'homme
et les grands prédateurs dont le loup et
puis yannick cadets chef du service aux
risques nature et forêt à la direction
départementale des territoires du doubs
vous nous direz notamment comment les
services de l'état prépare le retour du
loup bonjour à tous les trois merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
vous en avez l'habitude cette émission
c'est aussi la vôtre vous pouvez
interpeller nos invités leur faire part
de vos questions sur la page internet de
l'émission je me ferai d'ailleurs le
relais de vos questions tout au long du
débat et puis vous pouvez commenter sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le modeste qui
s'affiche dit mme paul fc comme dimanche
en politique franche comté alors
messieurs la confirmation est tombée en
tout début de semaine après une autopsie
c'est bien alou qui a été percuté par
une voiture sur la commune de chaffois
ans est prête à relier le 13 mars
dernier
des traces suspectes ont également été
signalés dans le courant de la semaine
du côté des fins dans le haut doubs
batterie serait de l'est est ce à dire
que le loup est définitivement
réinstallés en franche-comté
définitivement le sait pas encore pour
l'instant on sait que depuis 2003 il ya
des passages récurrents de
deux loups il ya quelques épisodes d'
attaque sur le cheptel domestique pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'installation ne
tient pas de reproduction comme dans
d'autres régions de france mais a priori
vu lol la dispersion de l'espèce oui
nous nous en tout cas on l'espère
puisque c'est une espèce qui manque à
notre un autre fournée qui va retrouver
sa place
on parle de passage néanmoins la
réinstallation le retour du loup de
manière durable sur le massif
il est inéluctable selon vous une élue
top il faudrait savoir toute façon ils
l'étaient ils étaient présents avant
faudrait voir les différences qui avait
qu'il y as entre
la période où il était présent et notre
période actuelle et puis voir ce qui
pourrait le gêner mais à priori le loup
s'adapte assez bien à toutes formes de
toutes sortes de milieux toutes formes
de fréquentation humaine donc a priori
il n'y a aucune raison pour qu'il ne se
réinstalle pauvres quand je comptais il
y avait calé les services de l'état
surveille bien évidemment la présence du
loup vous confirmez l'animal est
simplement de passage aujourd'hui en
franche comté
en tout cas on sera pas surpris qu'ils
colonisent la franche-comté parce
qu'effectivement il est installé dans le
massif alpin comme chacun sait il est
présent dans les vosges en
meurthe-et-moselle en moselle avec aussi
une installation note donc que l'arc
jurassien soit épargné entre guillemets
serait un peu surprenant donc qu'ils
passent et repassent ça sera sans doute
une de ses habitudes aujourd'hui par
contre actuellement on a on a cet
accident de chaffois 2018
sinon on ne connaissait antérieurement
que des épisodes en 2013 ou
officiellement on avait observé le loup
sur chatel blanc paroisse notamment et
pour le doubs je parle spécifiquement on
avait le départ on avait eu de la
prédation en 2011
sur un troupeau on a certainement
d'autres faire certes d'autres
observations qui ont été faites mais pas
forcément confirmée par contre on a des
suspicions régulière des suspicions on a
aussi à moi je parle vraiment du doubs
un c3 ces événements là on a également
de toute façon un réseau d'observateurs
un loup lynx qui est très présent sur le
terrain bénévolement à côté d'autres des
activités on a des informations mais on
n'a pas une présence avait réinstallé ça
on n'aura pas d'observations qui vont en
ce sens là
xavier broc et vous vous avez un doute
sur la présence du loup sur notamment le
massif du jura
pour moi il y est depuis que j'ai mon
attaque ça ne fait pas de doute même moi
j'habite aux rousses les suisses
régulièrement ils ont de la présence de
loups 1 2 les indices génétiques mois à
peine un kilomètre de l'endroit où
pâturent merise ou encore aux hivers
passés il ya des biches qui se sont fait
prédaté génétique loup est-ce qu'en
suisse il recherche la génétique plus
qu'en france c'est à dire que là il ya
une preuve scientifique alors qu'il y à
des loups juste de l'autre côté de la
frontière ça
par exemple moi pour vous dire quand
j'ai eu mon attaque s'est mis grand
canidé alors que tout le monde tous les
agents d'opi de la chasse pourrait
sauter du loup il n'y avait pas photo 1
s'est prise au cou c'est clair et c'est
vu l'environnement les bêtes protégés
par des chiens un parking turne tout ça
c'était difficile de dire que c'était un
chien qui avait pu faire autant de
dégâts mais par exemple sur la masse de
bêtes qui se sont fait tuer puisqu'il y
en a eu quand même 35 il ya eu aucun
prélèvement génétique de fait donc ça
laisse le doute quand même à chaque fois
et oui mais maintenant donc j'avais
raison sur sur le risoux toute façon
c'est en train de
on va pas on va pas dire forcément
s'installer parce qu'il faut attendre
des preuves mais mais ça passe ça passe
très très régulièrement entre la suisse
et la france et il ya une petite poche
qui est en train de bois d'amont il ya
eu un loup photographie et c est ce qu
on sait pourquoi le loup est encore
réinstaller de manière durable je pense
notamment il n'y a pas de meute a priori
ce sont que des individus solitaires est
ce qu on sait pourquoi il s'est paré
installé dans le jura lors qu'il est
monté jusque il arrive des apps il est
remonté dans les vosges est ce que c'est
parce qu'il ya une concurrence avec le
lynx par exemple est ce qu on sait
pourquoi il y en a pas de manière
pérenne dans le jura jusqu'à présent
n'ont pas forcément mais après ça sera
une question d'une question de temps il
faut voir si je vous disais tout à
l'heure force qu'est ce qui a changé par
rapport à l'époque où ils étaient
installés et puis ce qui pourrait
peut-être le déranger pour l'instant est
ce que la faune sauvage est assez les
pros potentiels sont passées présentes
je pense je pense que oui toute façon
franche comté normalement il ya les
forêts il ya du gibier exactement donc
normalement toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour qu'il se réinstalle
prochainement patrice rey de l'est le
retour du loup en france si les chiffres
et il y en avait 2 192 en 2016 360 en
2010 est l'objectif du gouvernement en
2023 c'est d'en avoir cinq cents alors
c'est une espèce protégée mais à quoi ça
sert d'avoir un loup à quoi ça sert les
loups déjà pour pourrait pas question de
quantifier une espèce comme ça je trouve
ça déraisonnable parce que c'est
c'est un point de vue politique et
s'allongera pas les choses sur le
terrain de dire ben on en veut 500 on a
la potentialité pour recevoir davantage
de luba laissons le soin de revenir
après en prenant les précautions qu'il
faut pour le pot pour les éleveurs le
loup après en france qui a ses comptes
fait passer des études sur l'impact
positif des espèces c'est à dire que ça
a été fait aux états unis notamment dans
le parc de yellowstone dix ans après son
introduction il ya beaucoup d'espèces
qui sont venus parce que le loup a
chamboulé un petit peu a remis en ordre
l'écosystème et ça a permis à des
espèces de revenir et ça ce point là on
ne prend pas en compte en france
alors c'est à dire comment ça marche
quand vous mettez un loup dans un
écosystème qu'est ce qui revient et
pourquoi d'autres espèces rares sur
l'exemple de yellowstone c'est
simplement ce qui se reproduiraient chez
nous c'est à dire que quand il n'y a pas
de prédateur il ya des des banques ou
des arts de don du lait qui sont très
importantes et qui se cache un tueur ne
m'en doit donc d'assur du surpâturage de
ces reprises ont dû laisser les
laissèrent les berges des chamois le
lourd revient ou un prédateur revient
mais surtout le loup et il va pas taper
dessus parce que je l'entends tout le
temps mais si c'est un prédateur qui
voyagera plus ou d'animaux ils vivent
depuis des millions d'années ensemble
donc c'est un équilibre qui se fait mais
par contre il va répartir ces animaux
différemment c'est à dire que la
visitation va reprendre la haye et le
sto notamment il ya des nouvelles
espèces de d'oiseaux qui sont venus le
castor est revenue la loutre également
voilà des insectes qui reviennent parce
que les écosystèmes change tout ça mais
bon on est aussi dans un environnement
qui est très différent je veux dire chez
nous et dégradé d'un mois typiquement
quand j'ai récupéré les terrains du
risoux cd zone natura 2000 présence de
grands tétras donc pour le souci qui
s'est posé en premier lieu est ce que
met pas tous vont pas bouffer du grand
tétras
c'était la question que les pâtes ou
pour ceux qui ne savent pas ce sont les
chiens de protection des troupeaux et
qu'ils sont censés protéger les
troupeaux de brebis notamment contre les
attaques du loup vous en vous avez parlé
de votre attaque en 2013 vous aviez des
patous à l'époque ça n'a pas empêché que
le loup s'en prennent à votre troupeau
n'est ce pas oui c'est ça comment
l'expliquer ce qu'ils ont fait les pâtes
ou quand le loup a attaqué alors moi
c'est difficile à dire puisqu'on
je n'étais pas là pour le voir j'ai vu
juste les dégâts moi j'ai ça fait
longtemps à cause de la présence du lynx
qu'on protège des troupeaux dans le jura
donc j'avais déjà à l'époque trois
chiens de protection et je faisais des
parcs de nuit comme on préconisait pour
pour faciliter le gardiennage des bêtes
par les chiens la nuit et moi manger une
attaque nocturne
on a quitté le troupeau après ce cas la
nuit et le lendemain matin on les a
retrouvés à huit kilomètres de l'endroit
où on les avait laissés et on a eu sur
cette attaque là je crois une vingtaine
de bêtes retrouver certifié nous sans
compter les bêtes que je n'ai pas
retrouvé
alors est-ce que le massif du risoux c1
ces immenses il ya beaucoup de d'eysines
et franchement c'est un boulot de dingue
de retrouver les bêtes prédaté faire
cohabiter le loup avec les activités
humaines et notamment l'élevage c'est
l'objectif du plan loup qui a été
présenté au mois de février
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ce plan loup
que font les services de l'état pour à
la fois protéger le retour enfin
garantir le retour du loup et protéger
les activités humaines et notamment
l'élevage
alors peut-être juste revenir sur
l'objectif du plan loup vous l'avez un
petit tout à l'heure c'est d'atteindre
l'objectif d'avoir 500 individus à
l'horizon 2023
c'est un objectif qui se veut concilier
à la fois la préservation de l'espèce
loup parce qu'on estime qu'il faut il en
faut au moins 500 pour avoir une
une présence viable du loup en france
mais qui se veut aussi être un objectif
qu'ils considèrent à côté de ça
l'activité le pastoralisme donc il ya
clairement un équilibre qui est
recherché par le plan loup entre
présence du loup manière viable
les activités économiques et
pastoralisme christophe un internaute de
diesse que l'on se pose la question de
savoir si la foudre doit être éliminé
ainsi que la grêle les chiens errants ou
les chiens de chasse le loup fait partie
de la nature c'est un fait on doit le
prendre
on doit prendre les dispositions pour se
protéger sans l'éliminer est-ce que ce
plan répond à ce défi patrice réglé il y
à des avancées il ya déjà dix recul est
notamment toujours toujours ses tirs
alors que c'est que c'était les montres
il ya quelques années à la demande l'an
dernier où il ya deux ans une étude ou
une ses fesses au muséum d'histoire
naturelle a démontré que le lait les
tirs étaient complètement inefficace et
de toute façon que ça permettait pas de
étire le clan loup prévoir 40 abattage
dans l'année maximum par maximum parce
qu'il ya des petits dérogation qui
permet certes on nous permet sans doute
de le dépasser mais ça a été montré
partout au canada aux états unis que que
le tir ne ne résolvait pas pas les
problèmes donc moi je vais revenir sur
un petit sur un petit point ce que je
ferai quand un petit peu la maison
depuis quelques années votre votre
maison et je me rappelle qu'en 2003 il
est invité à une émission pour le lynx
c'était juste après les premières
attaques la première attaque deux
du massif jurassien suite au retour du
loup en france et j'ai l'impression que
depuis quinze ans on a beaucoup
travaillé sur la communication on voit
que les enfants évoluent beaucoup
par contre on est toujours on a toujours
le même état d'esprit vis-à-vis du loup
c'est à dire c'est cette peur panique
d'animal qu'on a qu'on a inventé parce
que s'il y avait eu des problèmes et le
loup maintenant il y en a à peu près 400
emplois dans la peur panique simplement
si ses protégés moi pas du tout
aujourd'hui léger efficacement et c'est
très bien bon moi j'ai depuis deux ans
je m'étais jamais positionnée contre le
retour du loup je me positionne toujours
pas je sais bien contre je me positionne
je veux protéger mes brebis mois et
aujourd'hui on n'offre pas de solutions
pour les protégés j'ai mis tout en place
pour le fait que je te parle d'état
d'esprit c'est de façon globale au
niveau français au niveau de la
population
et comment ces traités il faut ça il
faut quand même bien avoir une scène qui
voit plus d' attaques de brebis en 15
exactement
mille quatre cents brebis attaqué par
des loubards en 2010 mille aujourd'hui
que c'est que cette peur du loup avec
tout ce qu'on a inventé depuis des
siècles en france c'est propre à la
france c'est à nag à ces attaques
énorme de sur les sur le bouton ses
propres à la france ça n'existe pas
ailleurs
mais si le loup est là on va les moutons
à danser mais pas dans ses pas danser et
d'en descendre dans ces quantités là ni
ni au canada ni aux et alors on nous
fait toujours passer pour des bons à
rien les éleveurs de moutons je veux
dire ne sais pas le but de se faire
bouffer des brebis se dire nous nos
pratiques moi j'ai je voulais ce prix va
changer on verra les choses différemment
quoi et quelles solutions pour protéger
notamment
nous serons alors moi je l'avais proposé
au début des années 2000 on l'a repris
après avec la création du plus grand
prédateur 2007 c'est-à-dire 2 2
d'uniformiser un petit peu la protection
des troupeaux donc tu parlais du lynx
tout à l'heure dans la salle jurassien
c'est à dire que les éleveurs et des
chiens qu'on mette à disposition que ça
où il avait des chinois
ça n'a servi à rien ça allait permettre
d'avoir d'avoir d'avoir des d'avoir déjà
une expérience des éleveurs parce qu'il
faut avoir cette expérience avec le
travail des chiens mais surtout de
mettre des chiens de savoir lire les
différents évoluer parce qu'avec un avec
le lynx est un chien ça suffit eh bien
ça tu feras pas avec le loup c'est
évident surtout parlé de me tout à
l'heure si une meute de loups qui
s'installe ce n'est pas qu'un chèque
alors de le prouver au problème c'est
pas simplement protéger mes brebis très
simple je vais acheter moi mettons les
tg on a pas loin de mille bêtes entre
les agneaux et brebis
j'achète deep dish de protection nickel
je suis embêté sauf que j'ai tout le
monde à dos les randonneurs c'est pour
ça que tu es pas l'état d'esprit global
des lingots ballon va pas changer l'état
d'esprit de toute la société et brooke
et et on va la changer
le fait d'avoir des chiens de protection
outre l'attaqué où il a été d'une
efficacité
ça vous a conduit aussi au tribunal deux
fois j'ai été deux fois condamné pour
morsures sur des touristes et j'ai été
condamné par 50 euros je sais bien ouais
mais c'est vraiment désagréable de de se
dire qu'en tant qu'éleveur on nous 1,6 à
prendre des chiens et le jour où il ya
un souci on se retrouve convoquée nulle
part à la gendarmerie pour faire une
déposition et après au tribunal donc là
il ya quand même un souci je les aimais
après les frais de l'erreur mais je
rentre depuis de quelques jours seront
très des abruzzes je vais depuis dix ans
en italie
en italie on organise des séjours
naturaliste avec le plus grand prédateur
depuis depuis des années donc je connais
très très bien moi aussi je connais très
bien il ya des zooms donc il ya on
estime entre un et trois millions de
visiteurs dans le parc national des
abruzzes
il ya des chiens absolument partout et
beaucoup de chiens sur sur les troupeaux
il n'y a jamais de souci j'avais moi
aussi il faut complètement
moi je n'ai jamais vu moi quand je te
dis ça je n'ai jamais vu de soucis
j'amène des groupes les chiens les
janvier les les chiens viennent au
contact des gens il n'y a pas de
problème ce faux complètement faux et
pourquoi et pour moi je suis saviez j'ai
fait jamais eu peur d'un mouton d agréer
les conneries j'ai des ânes
parce qu'on nous cite toujours l'exemple
je vous cite c'est moi qui te dit je
vais le souci maintenant on nous cite
l'exemple de la croatie parce que c'est
encore plus loin des fois qu'on ne soit
pas les voir moi par exemple j'ai des
amis qui sont éleveurs de moutons dans
la vallée d'aoste un mille deux cents
brebis
ils ont eu l'été passé des attaques
hostiles et moi quand je suis allé
ma femme et s'est fait mordre par l'un
des chiens pour te dire aviez broc et
est-ce qu'on peut donner des conseils
aux gens qui nous regardent que des
patous il y en a partout
les ja qui regardent que japonais y en a
marre on attendait j'aimerais qu'on
avance un peu est-ce que vous pouvez
donner un conseil aux randonneurs au
trailer aux vététistes quand on croise
un patou comment on se comporte alors
pour éviter d'être parce qu'on rentre
sur son territoire parfois et lui il a
un comportement de défense comment se
comporter quand il ya un chien de
protection comme ça pour première chose
à pas faire tu seras d'accord avec moi
c'est de pas fuir mais c'est facile à
dire parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont des
peurs paniques des chiens aussi
ouais c'est ça le problème est bon nous
on a fait avec jean marc landry des
journées sensibilisation 2 avec je pense
et je sais puis c'était cpe du haut jura
ou où le parc naturel du haut jura qui
organise et met on pourra jamais toucher
tout le monde et tu tombes sur sur un
procédurier
le gars il te fous au tribunal il va pas
chercher plus loin que ça moi j'ai vu
des gens des vététistes longer mon parc
le chien ne pas sortir juste aboyer le
mec il arrivait il tremblait totalement
les i vous êtes inconscient si un gamin
qui passe il va se faire égorger
est-ce que tu réponds à ça l'une des
clés du problème est là aussi c'est à
dire que c'est pas c'est pas mettre
toute la responsabilité sur les éleveurs
et sur les chiens protection s'est
informé pardonne on le fait depuis des
années leur noire au tribunal
on m'a dit que je devais être maître de
mes chiens en toutes circonstances alors
si on me dit ça c'est impossible dans ce
cas là je le prends plus de chiens
yannick année n'a pas pris la parole
depuis un moment interpellé par les
agriculteurs au salon de l'agriculture
sur cette question du plan loup emmanuel
macron a répondu si vous voulez me faire
dire qu'on supprimera les loups je ne le
dirai pas si vous voulez l'engagement
qu'on renforcera les moyens de
protection ou qu'on sortira les loups de
ces bassins je m'y engage
on voit que les moyens de protection ne
sont pas toujours efficaces
comment garantir
double objectif à la fois des loups est
à la fois des éleveurs protégé alors
garantir je sais pas si on peut
l'affirmer
le plan loup il apporte pas mal de
pistes 1 et 2 d'action bon je reviendrai
pas sur les pistes un peu connaissent en
suisse du loup biologie du loup ya tout
un volet dans le plan de la dessus après
il ya un volet qui est très axée sur la
prévention
donc c'est l'aide aux exploitants sur la
mise en place de clôtures grillagées
donc l'acquisition de chiens
l'accompagnement de chiens il ya aussi
peut-être les votes voisins ont fait oui
s'est fait attaquer et après il ya aussi
toute une structure structuration aussi
de l'élevage de ces chiens de la filière
canine et c'est peut-être avoir aussi à
progresser dans ce domaine là mais après
il ya les ya aussi bons les autres
systèmes les systèmes plus petites
clôtures électriques etc
après sur le volet dans le plan loup
aussi sur le volet cette fois
prélèvements vous avez parlé de 40 loup
en 2018 un quota de 40 nous il ne faut
pas qu'on ne faut pas faire croire que
c'est 40 langues qu'on va tirer comme ça
ou prélevé comme ça dans la nature
c'est un prélèvement qui est fait sous
certaines conditions c'est à dire que
notamment les pour le premier niveau qui
est le niveau des tirs de défense c'est
faire la demande d'un exploitant qui
fait l'objet de la taxe sur son propos
donc il fait cette demande au
département préfet du département qui va
analyser si le troupeau fait ou pas
l'objet d'un dispositif de protection et
s'il est possible de le protéger avant
toute chose et si c'est pas le cas on va
donner à l'exploitant la possibilité de
mettre en place un tir de défense vous
parlez d'abattage
on a une question d'yves qui nous
précise qu'il est suisse et nous dit je
me pose la question de la gestion du
loup avec les canton suisse du jura
neuchâtel sachant que le loup ne connaît
pas les frontières
qu'en sera-t-il s'il faut prendre la
décision d'abattre un loup franco suisse
alors ça non mais enfin bon on va
résonner sur le territoire français oui
mais sauf que on est on est réellement
la réalité c'est qu'effectivement le
loup il traverse quand il complètement
mais concrètement si ça fait quoi 100
150 jusqu'à 150 km par jour un loup ça
peut se déplacer une zone de 70 km mais
après ça dépend ça dépend d'eux
doudou
où est installée la meute et puis les
déplacements qu'ils ont à faire parquet
pour renault pour revenir sur le sur le
tir du loup on sait on sait très bien
que ce n'est pas une solution technique
et que c'est un choix politique
donc c'est ça qu'il faut c'est pour
contenter les éleveurs clc laisser les
groupes de pression qui en face mais non
infectés si je sais c'est que le famille
et si ça marchait depuis le temps il y
aura beaucoup moindre attaque
pourquoi ya beaucoup plus attaque si le
parce que moi j'ai pas de solution mois
j'expérimente de mon côté et personnes
on nous fait faire n'importe quoi des
fois je vais tilt est l'exemple on nous
dit les messieurs c'est quand même
frappant on a quand même ici un éleveur
quel sentiment d'être abandonnés clergé
local c'est la mairie clairement le tir
de défense dont je parlais tout à
l'heure c'est bien la possibilité de
dire on parlait de gironde avis toutes
les mesures en place donc le gars qui a
acquis à rien aujourd'hui
ç'a valu deux ans avant d'avoir un chien
de protection combien de temps il faut
et moi j'ai deux ou trois ans pour qu'il
fait depuis 2004 j'ai des chiens ou peu
que j'en ai eu c'est un qui peut
convenir aussi que l'exploitation
n'était pas protégeable très rapidement
ce n'est pas la question
moi c'est le ce que je ceux ci ont
rejoint insisté c'est que l'exploitant
ci fait l'objet d'une attaque vous
parlez d'un loup franco-suisse si vous
faites l'objet d'une attaque
répéter très rapidement on analyse la
situation
et si la seule solution est de permettre
à l'exploitant d'organiser un tir de
défense avec des personnes habilitées à
le faire on l'arrêté peut être délivré
dans ces cas là la franche comté du fait
qu'ils aient pas eu récemment de louie
identifié confirmé a été en quelque
sorte déclassé
quelles conséquences ça a notamment pour
les aides à la protection à la franche
comté
parce que le juin le jura le jura non il
ya toujours les aides puisque c'est par
département voilà y'a qu'à faut pas il
faut pas qu'il attaque il faut que les
observations qu il des observations
faites dans le jura l'an dernier bah ça
c'est toujours en cours et moche comme
des éleveurs donc les éleveurs sont
toujours aidé dans le jura mais ils ont
fait en cercle un pour y voir les
cyrillois ou simple de après t'être
cirque le hcc là où tell tale mieux
lotis parce qu'il ya plus d aides circle
de il y en a un petit peu moins mais ça
existe toujours dans du rhin ouais mais
en fait c'est largement insuffisant
oui mais pour les éleveurs mais moi j'ai
eu le cas puisque j'ai embauché 1 et
bergers toute une saison
ça fait partie des ailes du dispositif
des de l'héberger peuvent peuvent
salariés quelqu'un notamment à la
période critique pour protéger le
troupeau en plus d'avoir une présence
humaine supplémentaires il ya pas que
les chiens
alors concrètement il ya toujours ce
qu'ils exigent enfin les indemnisations
qui sont faites sur les bêtes tuées si
on a fait le constat qu'elle faisait ont
été tués par un loup ça c'est quelle que
soit l'existence d'un zonage types sert
qu'à autre chose
ensuite on dispose quand même en deux je
reviendrai sur les serbes et après mais
on dispose dans tous les cas aussi de
crédit d'urgence qui permettent
d'intervenir pour aider en situation de
crise dans la bibliothèque et sousse
valence est alors pour dire que ça
mettait du temps à annoncer une
exploitation si c'est très long moi j'ai
eu qu'à quand j'ai eu mes bêtes de tuer
je vous ai dit que mes brebis sur la
nuit elles ont fait by km j'étais seul
pour les retrouver dans les bois j'étais
seul donc ça veut dire qu'on a la charge
du travail de l'exploitation
il ya plein de joueurs qui font les
foins ce qui n'est pas mon cas mais il
faut faire les parcs de partout pour
agrandir donner à manger aux bêtes
on est vraiment dans l'urgence quand on
a des bêtes de partout qui abat tiens
j'en ai une la fois mené les garde pour
qu'il puisse l'avoir bon après il y en
avait tellement que ils m'ont dit quand
tu les vois tu les prends on va pas
faire le tour par tous mais pour un
éleveur guillet jeu c'est ingérable tous
fermés jusqu'au ça je comprends bien ce
que je veux juste dire l'accompagnement
humain c'est une chose que vous dire
c'est qu'il ya quand même des outils
financiers en tout cas qui sont
mobilisables pour aider ses manières
entraîné après pour en revenir juste au
cercle effectivement les grandes aide du
du plan loup qui sont prévues que ça
soit l'assistance technique le
financement des berges etc ne le sont
que quand on est dans des cercles et ses
serres sont possibles quand on a eu des
prédations et des attaques dans les deux
ans qui ont précédé
j'aimerais qu'on élargisse à la question
de l'élevage pour le le commun des
mortels on va dire on a beaucoup de
questions sur la dangerosité du loup
vous parliez tout à l'heure du mythe du
loup cruel et tous à une question par
exemple de marie qui nous disent ils on
en croise un lot lors d'une balade en
forêt représente-t-il une menace voilà
moi j'en croise plusieurs fois par an
depuis 10 ans voilée il me manque pas un
bout de doigt et manquerait c'est ça qui
est ça est la clé du problème tant qu'on
aura jamais un loup n'attaquera un
humain pour moi pour moi c'est
l'aventuré m'en fou tout ce qu'on a
raconté avant c'était à dd ça a pu
arriver c'est arrivé avec des loups
malades et loue des loups enragés
moi j'aimerais quand même quand même
mène une preuve formelle que c'est
arrivé avec des coussins c'est pas
possible moi j'en croise tous les ans
j'ai pigé pas de jets pas de souci avec
ça notre question d'amandine on dit que
le loup est inoffensif pour l'homme le
lous petits l'attaqué l'homme s'il est
blessé ou en meute ou si la fin un petit
enfant risque-t-il quelque chose
messieurs vous ne savez pas c'est ça
veut dire quoi cette mouvance est rien
et est ce que vous pensez que ce genre
de question est posée dans d'autres
émissions consacrées aux loups dans
notre pays
non non malheureusement non c'est ça qui
mais ça veut dire quoi que la france les
français ont un problème avec le louvre
c'est safran coup franc c'est bien sûr
moi je vous le dis depuis depuis lé
début de mission
moi j'aurais tendance à penser que comme
toute bête sauvage le loup a peur avant
nous après l'or en allant à mes brebis
pour moi bah bien sûr rencontre à chaque
fois moi j'ai le stress maintenant quand
j'arrive de me dire ce que j'en sais
quelque chose
voilà bah si c'est ça voilà ça chaque
mois maintenant j'arrive avant d'arriver
je lui ai dit bon qu'est ce qui s'est
passé est pas rare de voir avec sa vie
je voulais on parlait des aides des
aides d'administration je veux dire qu'à
l'époque en l'église attaque
avec le jura nature environnement et le
plus grand prédateur on avait fait un
appel à nos bénévoles
on avait trouvé en quelques jours ce
sont des personnes je passe tu te
souviens pour président
on avait proposé nous c'est de trouver
des solutions tout de suite pour pour
lui apporter des réponses
le fait remonter des binômes faire du
bruit qui jouait de la guitare fait
faire des trucs trouver des trucs tout
de suite comme pour frayer pour alors
parce que nous on a l'impression que tu
vas mettre n'importe qui à surveiller un
troupeau de moutons comme si c'était un
métier qu'on bien sûr mais c'était pas
un n'est pas le dire imaginez faire la
prison moi j'ai des chiens de protection
les brebis sortent déjà je veux dire un
collègue qui a l'habitude des moutons
l'eau soir va dans mon troupeau parce
que quelqu'un veut durer une brebis
meurent ils allaient voir le gars unis
mais disons qu est-ce qui garde ton
chien je veux dire deux nuits une
frontale qui imaginent des gens qui
connaissent rien ou ton là à quoi ça
sert bien sûr c'était pour ça pour dire
qu'il ya des gens qui sont qui sont
motivés qui s'il est des voix là on
n'est pas dans les alpes il n'y a pas de
cabanes comme moi j'ai eu les attaques
tu les fais dormir où les gens dehors
sous une bâche c'est ça va pas voilà
c'était le but c'était le but avoué
c'était de passer une nuit au plein air
à côté du mouton voilà c'était pour axa
s'est dit quelque chose
le sentiment il est bon mais dans la
pratique je sais bien que c'était
violent cela sera violent sur long terme
c'était pour apporter quelque chose de
ponctuel c'était c'est pour dire qu'il
ya des gens motivés qu'ils sont capables
de dire moi je vais passer ça on n'en
doute pas mais ça rêve n'est pas
forcément sur le long terme non mais sa
portée même ponctuellement un secret tu
vas pas mettre quelqu'un qui connaît
rien aux moutons à surveiller des brebis
surtout quand il ya une attaque de
brebis c'est c'est impossible de la
mettre dedans en se disant que j'avais
entendu mais déjà des gens quand ils et
vous en pleine journée ils en ont peur
une présence humaine allait peut-être
suffire à faire affaire avec arte on a
bien compris qu'on ne mettra pas
d'accord en tout cas merci on a pas de
désaccord
profond avec xavier merci à tous les
trois c'est la fin de cette émission
déjà merci beaucoup d'avoir évoqué avec
nous ce retour programmé du loup en
franche comté dans un instant la suite
de dimanche en politique francis
letellier reçoit florian philippot pour
tout de suite votre flash d'information
bon dimanche à tous